rupert sheldrake needs no introduction
he's an author and a researcher in the
field of
parapsychology with a phd from cambridge
and biochemistry
this channel is dedicated to
conversations around theories of
everything
consciousness free will god and topics
that are cognate to that it's also about
putting a spotlight on those who i don't
think get as much credit
as they should and you can see my john
moffatt interview as an example of that
now rupert has plenty of credit he's
done many ted talks
but there is one aspect which i find a
significant shame
it's unfair that rupert has been
mischaracterized and that even i have
had
false views about him because of what i
read online
that i thought was legitimate but wasn't
we get to this specific issue toward the
latter half of the conversation
however unfortunately my video nor peter
glenos who's my colleague
neither his video recorded either way
this is an important issue enjoy
why do you think physicists particularly
theoretical physicists don't listen to
you
what's going on why aren't these ideas
taken seriously your ideas
well um i'm primarily a biologist so
i mean i i did the question be better
directed to biologists and physicists
um well the fact is that what i'm
putting forward are views which are
considered by some to be heretical i'm
trying to
find models and ways of doing science
that go beyond
the dogmas of mechanistic materialism
now that is inevitably controversial
because that is still the dominant
orthodoxy or paradigm
and there are a lot of people who have a
heavy investment in it
particularly militant atheists i mean
this is their worldview their belief
system
and i'm trying to show the way to a
broader and more inclusive
and i think more interesting kind of
science which is
the point of my relatively recent book
sounds set free which has just come out
in a new edition in britain
called the science delusion in britain
so it's not true that everyone has a
problem with it i have a lot of friends
within the scientific world it's just
that
most of them keep their heads beneath
the parapet because
anyone who advocates on controversial
views in science is worried about
endangering their career losing their
grants etc etc
um but among in the scientific world
there are lots of people
who have much more open-minded views
than you'd gather from
listening to science popularizers
there is a sense that this paradigm of
this mechanism the universe as a
mechanism
this materialism is a cultural phenomena
uh sort of a scientific paradigm
that will have maybe an expiration date
something along the lines of
thomas kuhn scientific uh revolutions
and that we are maybe seeing an era that
might come to an
end i'm curious what you think will
cause that era to come to an end
and if we could throughout the interview
could we touch on
uh whether or not this universal view
of the universe as a machine
is historically grounded what was the
view
that peoples had before this sort of
mechanism to the universe
that's mechanistic view of the universe
well i mean the the history of science
the subject i've studied and
it helps a lot in thinking about this um
is it shows that in medieval europe i
mean science grew up in europe so we're
looking primarily
european history if we're looking at
modern science and of course
it grew up in the islamic world and in
india and china in different ways but
science as we now know it grew out of
its european roots
primarily and in medieval europe the
general world view was a kind of
christian animism the nature was alive
living organisms were truly alive the
earth
was a living being mother earth the
stars and the planets were intelligences
there was living beings with souls and
intelligence the whole cosmos had a soul
and animals and plants had souls um
even magnets had souls that we we lived
in an animated world
um and the reason we call animals
animals is because the latin word for
soul is anima
um they're beings with souls so what the
mechanistic revolution in the 17th
century
did was to say no this is completely
wrong this is just superstitious stuff
the world isn't made up of living beings
it's made up of inanimate matter that
works in a machine-like way
and the stars and planets are not alive
in any way they're just inanimate and
animals and plants are just machines and
so are we
that was the mechanistic revolution and
that has given us modern science as we
know it
but this was built in from the beginning
the idea that nature is dead inanimate
in the chemical
so you mentioned this idea of the
superstitious
in the western european context there's
this divide
between the supernatural and the natural
and this
divide sort of comes along with the
evolution of western theology
but there's a professor by the name of
howell who writes
on the supernatural as understood by
members of the ojibwe
a native group in north america and he
writes
that the appellation of supernatural
persons
if applied to characters in the midst of
northern ojibwe people is a complete is
completely
misleading if no other reason than the
fact that the concept of the
supernatural
presupposes the concept of the natural
the latter is not present
in ojibwe thought because an
understanding of the supernatural is
predicated on an
understanding of the natural the very
very ancient hellenic concept
more primitive societies if you would
primitive in quotes
lack this natural supernatural divide
considering that our science grew out of
this divide between
oh here's the natural where you know we
have turnips and mycorrhizal fungi
and forests and things and then there's
the supernatural
demons angels consciousness
do you feel that this is a sort of false
divide
and that the time will come where this
natural and supernatural will collapse
the material in the conscious
oh absolutely i think it's a false
divide and i think we're
already coming out of it the divide
occurred
essentially in the 17th century and
before that in the middle ages in europe
the
form of theology that was dominant for
example in saint thomas aquinas
uh was didn't have the supernatural as a
separate category god was in nature the
whole of nature was animated by the
divine
and the whole of nature was prepa was
motivated to move towards the divine it
was
god was in nature nature was in god and
um the there just wasn't that division
but the mechanistic theory of descartes
created that division quite explicitly i
mean that's
why it's called cartesian dualism and
what descartes said is the whole of
nature is a mechanical machine-like
inanimate
but there's also consciousness and
consciousness
consists who has three categories god
angels
and demons and things and spirits and
human minds
and human minds are the only conscious
things in the natural world
mysteriously interacting with brains he
thought in the pineal gland
and that all of the rest guard angels
and demons and spirits are supernatural
they're outside or beyond nature
so that created this dualistic split
which
has underlying western thought since the
17th century
and in the 19th century um
the the there was a kind of rebellion
against it from two sides by idealist
philosophers on the one hand who said no
we don't want two things consciousness
and matter we just want one thing
consciousness
and matters sort of dumb down mind
that's the idealist philosophy
and but the other side became
predominant materialists
who said there aren't two things uh
matter
and consciousness is only one thing
matter that's what materialism is the
doctrine that matters the only reality
therefore god and angels and spear
spirits and demons simply don't exist as
whole supernatural realm is pure mumbo
jumbo imagination and superstition
and um the only thing left of that realm
uh in this view of nature was the human
mind then the human mind has to become
simply an emergent phenomenon from human
brains created by physical processes
inside the head
and so materialism creates
it has a view of the universe as being
completely non-conscious
and mechanical and the very existence of
human consciousness is a terrible
embarrassment for materialism we ought
not to be conscious and in fact
materialist philosophers have spent at
the later part of the 20th century and
they're still trying to do it now
trying to prove that we're not conscious
or that
if we are the consciousness doesn't
actually do anything
uh we don't really have free will it's
just a kind of epic phenomenon
or another way of talking about the
physical activity of the brain
so i think that this world view which is
what we've all been brought up with
and which we've exported to the rest of
the world the same worldview is taught
in schools in china
india south america africa everywhere
nowadays um because of the prestige and
the successes of science and technology
um i think we're emerging out of it and
that's the whole point of my book sunset
free i take the ten dogmas of
contemporary science
and show how actually science itself is
growing out of them and showing us the
way out of them
and the for example the dogma that
our minds are nothing but our brains the
activity of our brains
um that's being challenged in several
ways even today within
the academic and scientific world partly
through the implausibility of the
materialist worldview
partly through the intractability of the
hard problem
and what it's led to is the emergence of
a new kind of pan psychism the idea that
there's a difference of degree between
our consciousness and the rest of nature
not a kind
that even electrons atoms and so on have
some degree of consciousness
and therefore consciousness can emerge
in brains not from totally non-conscious
matter but from less conscious matter
and that's surprisingly popular at the
moment within the academic world
do you have any opinion on daniel
dennett's explaining consciousness book
[Music]
yes i mean obviously what he's trying to
do is explain consciousness away
his book's called consciousness
explained but as many people have said
it
we better call consciousness explained
away
dennit is a um a true believing hardcore
materialist um who um
he makes it clear that his total
opposition is to cartesian dualism
which i just mentioned the idea there's
a supernatural realm out there
but he thinks the only alternative to
that is hardcore materialism
and uh i think he's wrong i think there
are
several alternatives including pan
psychism
um but he then goes to enormous lengths
to try and explain consciousness away
um that he wants to get rid of
any kind of magic or the problem is of
course that
you know it's very hard to be a
consistent materialist if you believe
that you're a machine yourself from your
mind's nostril
about nine but complex computer then
your belief in materialism is just
something that your mind makes you
believe your
your brain makes you believe uh
materialists
i'd like to think they're an exception
to their in philosophy
that they adopt their own views on the
basis of reasons science and evidence
but actually their own philosophy says
that they have no choice in doing that
they're simply programmed to believe in
materialism
um a meme or a meme complex has captured
their brain
and forces them to believe in it um and
they're not aware that it's
um they're being compelled to believe in
it
so because their consciousness is a kind
of illusion anyway i think the problem
with
dennett and other materialist
philosophers is that
basically they're self-refuting
are you opposed to reason or do you see
the limitations and reason first of all
we'd have to define reason
for the of audience
i'm not opposed to reason i spent my
whole career as a research scientist
publishing papers in peer-reviewed
journals and
doing experiments and writing books
which i hope
are rational um well i think
what reason is is simply a function of
the human mind to do with
looking at evidence um you know
evaluating things in terms of
probability and so forth
i don't think it's some mysterious
property with a capital are
that makes us semi-divine and separate
from the rest of nature
um and you know there's so
militant materialists go around saying
they believe in science and reason i
mean richard dawkins for example
has the richard dawkins foundation for
reason and science
um but what they mean by reason
is their world view
and i find the best way of testing how
serious they are about
reason and science is to bring out the
subject of telepathy for example
um there's a lot of evidence for it
there's lots of experiments that suggest
it really happens
it drives material is crazy because it
doesn't fit their world view so they
think it ought not to happen therefore
all the evidence must be flawed
but if you try and have a debate with a
materialist about
telepathy they just get angry um
because they can't look at the evidence
scientifically or reasonably um even
though they claim to believe in reason
and science which
if you have any materialist friends this
is a very good test
bring up the subject of telepathy and
see how reasonable and scientific they
are
in discussing it most of them are
certainly not very reasonable or
scientific
even though they claim to believe in
reason with a capital r
so i see reason with a capital r as a
kind of slogan
for a materialist world view rather than
a genuine devotion
to the principles of rationality
you mentioned pan psychism does that
have a role
in relation to your belief in a
a telepathy between organisms between
life and to expound on this idea of
pansychism
there's a certain sense that our
conscious has an unconscious
but i think if we go deeper is it fair
to say that our unconscious has an
unconscious and that this
might act as a bedrock for the emergent
consciousness that we that we see
that is to say if we go further if we go
down this iceberg
is there a point where my unconscious is
unconscious overlaps with with yours and
that we are actually
not really individuals but emergent
beings from a
sort of bedrock as the hindus would say
um that we are both dreams in this
larger dream of vishnu
or as crucial might say that we are
within the mind of god
well i think that's ultimately the case
yes
um and i think that the idea that our
own
personal unconscious is part of a larger
unconscious is
i mean after all quite well known idea i
mean this is the basis of jung's idea of
the collective unconscious
and jung the psychologist cj
young had this idea that we all draw
upon this collective unconscious which
is a
kind of collective memory a collective
human memory
and this underlies our dreams the
archetypal patterns we experience in our
lives and so forth
um and this is very similar to my own
ideas about morphic resonance i mean my
own
main hypothesis about memory
is that it works by a kind of resonance
from the past
morphic resonance i call it um which
means that each species has a kind of
collective memory not just humans
um all have a collective memory and most
of our
habits um are unconscious i mean
nature but the general theory that i'm
putting forward is that the so-called
laws of nature are more like habits the
whole of the universe
has a kind of memory um and there's
the habits of nature underlie all the
regularities within the physical
and chemical and biological and
psychological realms
they're all habitual and habits are
generally unconscious
in us as well therefore the role of
consciousness
is always taking place against the
background of habits and
unconscious habits and collective memory
that's the view that i've
that i myself adopt so
do we have free will i understand what
you're saying
implies that we're influenced by
previous arrangements like matter has
been arranged in a certain
conglomeration i think that's lee
smolin's principle of
precedence which reminds me of the
morphic resonance theory
just in physics form is there room for
free will do you personally believe in
free will
oh of course i think everybody does i
don't i mean there are people who
pretend they don't or argue in seminar
rooms that it doesn't exist
but i haven't met anyone who actually
really believes that they're an
automaton with no free choice
and our entire legal and educational
system is based on belief in free will
if your brain makes you do it and you
have no free will then
that would be a perfect defense in any
law court
for being convicted of any crime um
so i think everyone believes in it and i
think rightly so
and of course we don't have infinite
freedom of choice in all matters we're
influenced by our environment our
background our conditioning our habits
our
frameworks of thought like paradigms um
we're influenced by all these habits but
there's a certain measure of choice we
have all of us
i mean we all chose to be talking
together right now i don't believe i was
programmed by my genes or by anything
else to be talking to kat and peter at
this exact moment
um and i don't suppose you'd be you you
were programmed to do it either so i
i personally i see it as a non-issue and
a kind of artificial
debate that i'm not very interested in
so so how do you respond to the
reductionist attitude of causation just
why did you make the decision you made
because your neurons did so and so and
you just keep asking why
why because because because until you
get to some wall
that you could not have possibly caused
as your mother gave birth to you or the
big bang initial conditions
what what's your response to that line
of argumentation
well i think even reductionists would
agree that chance plays a large role
in what happens in nature i mean the
neo-darwinian theory of evolution which
is their preferred
theory of evolution uh puts all the
creativity ultimately in transmutations
so none of them are saying that nature
is totally determined
so just sorry just to quickly interject
i'm not talking about lap classes demon
where
it's completely fixed but but even if we
allow for quantum fluctuations
they the materialist might still say
that
the randomness is not dependent on you
either so whether you're determined or
it's random on top of determinism
it's still not within your control so
what's what would you say to that
well then i'd say to them well how come
you believe in materialism
do they what's the reason for them
believing themselves turn the tables
in this argument and say what's the
reason if you're a materialist for you
believing in materialism
what's caused you to believe in that and
they probably
they'd say well you know they'd have to
say trans events in the brain
conditioning etc they probably say i've
been convinced of it by
evidence by reason by the scientific
method
i believe in reason and science and then
you say well okay well can you explain
those in terms of materialism
um because they imply free choice they
imply
choosing a world view on the basis of
evidence
and that's why i was saying earlier i
think the materialist position is
self-refuting
their own belief in materialism um
depends on the assumption that they're
free to choose on the basis of evidence
and reason
um and so if they're going to say
everybody else's choices are totally
conditioned by
nerve impulses neurotransmitters and
random events in the brain
um then again uh there you're the in the
end or at least quite quickly
i think one will find that they're
making an exception for themselves
there is a um brilliant comic
calvin hopps where calvin and hobbes are
going through
monster land and by their being led by a
monster tour guide
and the monster tour guide uh and calvin
hops
run across a monster who's repeating the
number nine
right so he's saying nine nine nine nine
nine and
calvin asks the monster tour guide what
is he doing he says the monster tour
guide says oh he's just repeating
nine in a very deterministic sequential
order so no they keep walking
and they come across another monster and
the monster is repeating
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
same number over and over and over again
just like the monster beforehand they're
identical
and he says okay is
this monster uh what's this monster
doing
and the monster tour guide says oh he's
saying numbers
at random totally undeterministically
they all happen to be nine there's a
great sense that we couldn't tell
whether or not an
ordered sequence was truly chaotic or
truly ordered
and whether or not the phenomena of
nature that we see in the conscious mind
is order
or some you know random pattern that
seems to be ordered
would you say that this applies to
whatever you find
as the bedrock of consciousness
furthermore
you mentioned how you don't believe
consciousness is purely material
and therefore explained away but at the
same time too
you recognize that the divide between
sort of supernatural substance something
closer to
um sarge radical freedom that
consciousness is this sort of free agent
is isn't necessarily real because it
still recognizes that divide
what is the bedrock of consciousness if
it's neither material nor
this sort of uh substance that
transcends all material
and is it ordered or is it random or
could we never tell
well i think in the end it's a choice of
world view isn't it and
i think that the world views we have
depend on our experience as well as on
reason most people who have a religious
world view
i mean the great mystics in all
religious traditions
believe there's a form of consciousness
beyond the human level
of which our consciousness is a small
part not on the basis of reason logic
calculations or mathematics but on the
basis of mystical experiences where they
feel themselves to be part of a vastly
greater consciousness
and this is what the great indian rishis
were
experiencing in their retreats in the
himalayas and still do
and what the buddha experienced in his
moment of enlightenment
and the it's what the great christian
mystics have experienced and what the
sufi mystics experience
it's it's in all traditions in shamanic
traditions too
people don't go to classrooms and learn
about spirits
they have experiences of experiencing
forms of consciousness
other than our own and ultimately over
kind of ground of all consciousness
itself which we can experience through
mystical experience
meditation and other spiritual practices
can help us to
more likely makes it more likely that
we'll have these kinds of experiences
these tell us if we listen to our and
pay attention to our inexperience if we
have these experiences
there's a greater form of consciousness
of which our end minds apart
and anyone who has that world view
which is the world view of all the
world's religions
and almost everyone who's got a kind of
spiritual worldview takes the view that
consciousness
is underlies the universe and uh our own
consciousness is part of that a kind of
fractal version of that ultimate
consciousness
um then anyone who takes that view would
see
the universe in a different way from
someone who starts from materialist
assumption
materialism after all isn't based on
experiences and it's a purely
intellectual theory
that denies other forms of consciousness
that's its first step his first move
is to say by definition there are no
forms of consciousness
outside the universal within the
universe everything is made of
unconscious matter
and so far as we are conscious then it's
just a product of our brain
material brain activity that's their
worldview
and um it's a belief system and people
who are deeply embedded in it
um are resistant to any evidence that
would
take them beyond it however when you
look at the actual life history of
people who used to be materialists who
aren't anymore
including me then um
what you find is that what's persuaded
people that consciousness is more
pervasive than
um just a product of the brain is
personal experience
mystical experiences for example in
near-death experiences
often for many modern people through
psychedelic illuminations
and through other experiences which
convince them that their mind is more
than just the activity of their brain
the materialist would then
counter by saying well that's just an
illusion
but then you have the situation what do
you trust most do you trust an
intellectual theory
with a originating basically in its
present form in the 19th century
as an attempt to get rid of dualism
religion
and so forth as part of an atheistic
crusade
um a theory about science um or do you
accept your own experience
and personally i think it's more
scientific to
accept experience because the very word
empirical on which science is based
means to base it on
experience and
the greek word empirical means
experience and in french
the the word experience means experience
and experiment
um so it's not as if our own experience
is irrelevant
to understanding consciousness it is
consciousness
what the heck are psychedelics doing
beside a neurochemical
reaction how are they doing what they do
and
something else i've been interested in
that's part one something else i've been
interested in is
the difference between lsd is
psychedelic and then there's dmt it's
almost like in a class of its own
but they're both psychedelics what the
heck is going on with dmt and is there
any
ontol is there any reality to the
entities that people see
so that is what are psychedelics doing
besides the
reaction in your brain and then
furthermore what separates lsd from dmt
well i think i think you know
what the answer you give depends on your
world view if you start from a
materialist worldview
then what they're doing is changing you
know they're interfering with
neurotransmitter receptor sites in the
brain and so forth
and leading to distorted brain activity
and on fmri scans of people on lsd
or on other psychedelics you can
actually see
differences in brain activity different
areas connect up together
all that for a materialist would be all
you need to say
and the conscious changes in
consciousness they produce are just
illusions like everything else produced
by the brain
they're just producing a different set
of illusions and there are so
there are materialists who take
psychedelics who
would explain their own experience in
those terms
however the experiences themselves
don't seem like just something happening
in the brain people feel they're getting
true insight into some much more
profound
aspects of the mind that's why they're
called psychedelics means psyche
revealing
mind revealers that's what they are
aldous huxley coined the term
to know to give this idea that what
they're doing is revealing something
about the nature of the mind
one thing they do is shut down the
default mode network
the chattering mind that goes on uh in
all the time when we're ruminating or
worrying or being anxious or just
thinking
they shut down the default mode network
so does meditation
and you know when people are in deep
meditative states that also shuts down
the default mode network
and when you shut down the chatter
that's going on inside the mind
then some people would argue i would
argue that the mind then becomes more
open
to connecting with deeper or further
or other forms of consciousness that are
around us and
of which we're apart but we're not
normally aware because they're shut out
by all this chatter
just like you can see people in
beautiful landscapes
who just are completely unaware of the
landscape because they're busy doing
facebook on their smartphone or
something their
mind is completely occupied by this
foreground of chatter and distraction
and um some would argue that
psychedelics shut out
this distraction which other methods can
do too like
near-death experiences through trauma
um and meditation and so forth
other spiritual practices um and
opens up to seeing things that are there
all the time but which we don't normally
see
or experience so that's the world view
of people who take a more spiritual
interpretation of these but
you know again you're going to come back
to what people's world views are the way
they interact
how do you see it well i see it in terms
of
wider forms of consciousness um to which
we can
gain access and i think that the
with visionary substances like um lsd
and ayahuasca where many people have
visual
experiences um i think what they do is
open up
the realm of the imagination we have
this imaginal realm
anyway every night when we dream we're
creating
scenes that aren't the same as reality
that are
in some sense illusory um i think
it's the same kind of faculty we have
when we're dreaming
but we enter it from the waking state in
a much more vivid and enhanced state
through certain kinds of psychedelics
now i think dmt um
is produces something for some people
more like
a near-death experience it takes you
beyond that realm
into some further realm of the mind or
greater realm of consciousness um
which is sort of beyond the realms that
nsd would normally take you into which
are more
like enhanced versions of the dream
state
um more into a kind of mystical state of
unity of consciousness
um so anyway these are
different psychedelics work differently
for different people it's hard to
generalize
but from what i've learned from talking
to people and reading about these things
and
partly through my own experience i think
they're
opening it up to these wider realms of
experience and i think that actually one
of the things that is causing the
cultural shift
that we're all talking about at the
moment is psychedelics and if you read
that book
came out last year by michael pollan on
psychedelics called
how to change your mind it was a new
york times bestseller for months
you may well have seen it um michael
pollan
uh is a scientific journalist
and his other books on things like food
the omnivores dilemma
his book on plants the botany of desire
um it we did a book on the new science
of psychedelics the research that's
going on uh into the effects of
psilocybin magic mushrooms in reducing
depression
uh in curing people who've got various
mental
illnesses these have therapeutic uses
these psychedelics
and as part of the book he says that he
started the book as a materialist and
atheist
and um but he took psychedelics he felt
as an investigative journalist he should
experience what he's writing about
and by the end of the book he's become a
kind of pan psychist you know he thinks
consciousness is much more widely
distributed in nature it's not just in
human brains it's in
trees and plants and animals in the
earth in the natural world
and i think many people who've obtained
psychedelics undergo
that kind of conversion experience where
they realize it's not all just about us
and about human brains
and that then leads to a wider
questioning of the materialist worldview
and the scientific paradigm
so my point is that most people change
their minds
as he did through experience rather than
through argument
he then becomes much more interested in
and psychist philosophy as a result of
his own experience
and his book after all is called how to
change your mind
there is a sense when you were talking
about meditation
and given that this is an ancient
practice that
sort of the practices we have in society
that we do for reasons we know not of
uh tend to be ahead of in some
very serious sense the sciences so for
example
we would wash our hands before we
understood germ theory
we would uh take the bark off of the
aspirin tree to cure our headaches
before we understood its chemical
composition
these practices pre-date
many of the scientific reasons and uh
rationalizations as to why we do that
is it for this do you believe that for
this reason the mystic practitioner
will always be in some sense ahead of
the
scientist ahead of the rationals
yes i think when it comes to
understanding consciousness the people
who understand it best are the ones
who've
experienced it most systematically and
you know if you have a tibetan monk
that's spent you know hours a day
meditating for years
they're basically studying the nature of
their own minds from within
they're going to understand more about
it than someone who's done psychology
101 at a university
and as an undergraduate uh even though
the
graduate is going to emerge with a
degree that says they've got a degree in
psychology
the tibetan monk who may have no degree
is going to have a vastly deeper
understanding
may not have a deeper understanding of
how to measure
brain waves with encephalographs and the
technologies of
measuring nerve impulses and that kind
of thing but
in terms of the study of consciousness
itself then they've gone far further
um i mean what modern science is
mechanistic science is really good at
making machines
it's about its metaphor as machinery
it's really good at machines we're
talking through a computer now and
through the internet and
science is unrivaled no tibetan monk
could possibly come up with a smartphone
or
a you know an internet system you need
engineering science and technology for
that but when we come
to consciousness then i think they're
far in advance
of anything that's come out of any
science lab
that i've seen in terms of understanding
the true nature of the mind
read this critique of the dog experiment
and i want to know what your response to
this is this is from richard wiseman
someone said he is not convinced he
argues keep as
in richard wiseman have we told people
what the dog experiment is
no let us please actually please
uh well we should explain this to
because no one will know what we're
talking about otherwise
well i've i i've been interested in
telepathy um
for a long time and partly because i
think
if you have a field theory of minds and
a field theory of social groups which i
do
then i would actually predict telepathy
as a form of communication between
bonded members of social groups
and when i thought about this first i
realized it would apply to
animals animal groups like
packs of wolves or stalks of flocks of
birds or schools of fish
should be related through a field that
relates the individual members of the
group
and they'd remain connected by this
field even at a distance which would
mean a change in one could affect the
others
similar analogous to quantum
non-locality where particles have been
part of the same system when they move
apart
uh if one changes the other
instantaneously
uh is it takes up a different position
like
one polarization polarized photon the
other one will immediately adopt the
ultimate the opposite polarity
quantum non-locality or entanglement so
something like that i predicted would be
going on with animals
so then i thought well no one's looked
at telepathy and animals
in the human realm it gets sort of
associated in some people's minds with
sort of spooky
green light imaginary
star superstition and so forth treat it
scientifically if it exists it should
have evolved if animals if it exists it
should be bearing animals
then i ask people who have animals dogs
cats parrots horses and other animals
if they'd ever experience their animals
picking up their thoughts or intentions
and overwhelmingly people i got i've had
more than six thousand case histories on
my database
yes lots of people have noticed it and
one of the most common
phenomena and one of the most testable
is
um dogs that know when their owners are
coming home
about 50 of dogs going waiters door or
window while the person they're most
bonded to is on the way home from work
or from holiday or whatever
members of the household know when
they're coming because the dog goes and
waits for them
this happens even if they come at
non-routine times even if they come in
non-familiar vehicles
so um the skeptics said to me oh that
can't be true it's impossible
it's just make-believe people dote on
their pets and they imagine
it's just a coincidence they forget all
the times they're wrong and so forth
um they hadn't done any experiments but
they confidently dismissed it so i set
up an experiment
where we filmed the place a dog waited
this is a dog that regularly did it
um we filmed the place the whole whole
time leona was out so we could see
objectively when the dog went to the
door or window
um i they only went at least five miles
away
dogs even the most sensitive dogs can't
smell things for more
more than about half a mile away and
then the wind has to be in the right
direction
um they didn't know when they were
coming home i told them by mobile
phone at randomly chosen time go home
now
um and they didn't travel in a familiar
vehicle they took public transport or
traveled on
borrowed bicycles or in taxes different
taxi each time
so there were no familiar signs no
routine the people at home didn't know
when they were coming they didn't know
in advance when they were coming home
and in these experiments over and over
again in hundreds of trials
the dog went and waited at the door for
10
minutes before the person came home
there were a few times they didn't do it
when the dog was sick
or mostly the few exceptions were when
there was a [ __ ] on heat in the next
apartment
so it proved the dog could be distracted
but most of the time
highly significant statistically i then
appeared on a tv program in britain that
described this research and they showed
one of these experiments
richard wiseman is a hardcore
materialist atheist skeptic type
who is a member of the committee for
skeptical inquiry a
militant campaigning skeptic so
he criticized it saying oh it's just
routine and they hear the car sounds
and i'd already explained you know we
that's the first thing we thought of we
spent a year
doing hundreds of experiments showing
it's not but you it's still on tv you
said well it's obviously just routine
so i invited him to do experiments with
the dog himself
he did with his own car his own
randomizing system
i lent him one of my cameras um he did
three experiments with the dog in the
same place i'd done it
in every one of them the dog was waiting
when she came home the owner came home
it was at the window 78 of the time when
she was on the way home
of that period 78 was at winter
when she wasn't coming home it was the
window an average of four percent of the
time it occasionally went to look at
passing cats as it did in my experiments
and to my astonishment wiseman then
appeared on television and in the media
to saying he'd refuted the psychic dog
phenomenon
and that the dog had gone to the window
before she came home and therefore it
failed the test
when i pointed out to him that actually
after his supposed failing of the test
when it had gone to the window for some
other reason not waiting just going for
a brief visit
um um that you look at the rest of his
own data and they showed this massive
effect statistically significant
he said oh you can't look at that data
that's reading the date reading
data patterns into the data after the
dog's already failed the test
and now everyone who's looked at richard
wiseman's analysis of the data
and who's looked at his data it's now
been discussed in several books there's
a book called
randy's prize about materialists and
skeptics
there's a book called heretics by
somebody who interviewed wiseman went
into this whole story
it's become a classic case of skeptical
treatment
of evidence and distortion of what went
on
so i mean read what he said and i'll
tell you in this context
what it's about sure i'll paraphrase for
brevity
he essentially said that it's not
surprising that the dog would be on the
porch before it comes home because
that it just the longer the
owner is away the more likely the dog is
to wait on the porch
and it's more evidence of the dog
anticipating the arrival of the owner
instead of knowing through psychedelic
mystery sorry through
psychic abilities and then he goes on
further to criticize that
your work hasn't been peer-reviewed in
peer-reviewed journals
but only in books and that this means
that your methodology has not been fully
described making it difficult to
properly assess
the validity of the methodology well you
see unfortunately this is a perfect
example of lying
and deception and his phd thesis was on
deception
the psychology of deception he's a
magician he's a skilled deceiver
and let me explain why that's deceptive
first of all
the dog doesn't go to the window more
and more as time goes on we did control
experiments where the owner didn't come
home at all
during the whole experimental period of
more than four hours
and it doesn't go it's just more or less
a flat line he's knows that he's seen
the graphs i've shown in the data
secondly all the data from these
experiments is published in
peer-reviewed journals
and it's all on my website you can
actually see
pdfs of the papers in peer-reviewed
journals website
sheldrate.org research section
unexplained animal powers telepathy with
dogs
all the data quantitative data there um
there was a film done from an austrian
television company which you can also
see on my website a
skeptical science unit where they showed
this phenomenon
very clearly um so
it is in peer-reviewed journals uh it
has been
subjected to scientific scrutiny it has
been done in the correct way
um i have taken into account you know
the
dog going to the window more and more
wiseman's own data show this
and yet you see like you reading the
kind if you read wikipedia which is
being captured by skeptics
all the areas to do with me psychic
research alternative medicine
they're all full of this kind of
misinformation so
you're i mean you're an open-minded chap
you want to find out about this you go
and look it up online and that's what
you find
the reality is completely different and
what we're seeing is particularly with
wikipedia is
the defense of a materialist paradigm by
the systematic and deliberate distortion
of evidence filtering out positive
evidence
putting in snide incorrect results like
sneering remarks like that it's not in
peer-reviewed journals online books
absolutely untrue uh and he knows it's
untrue
i mean he's seen my peer-reviewed papers
i mean in private when i talk to richard
wiseman
he's a perfectly reasonable personally
he's quite funny
um but as soon as he gets onto his sort
of
podium as the media skeptic
it's astonishing that he can say things
like that
and get away with it well he doesn't get
away with it actually
look at a website called skeptical about
skeptics
and you'll find a dossier on his
deceptions in this and other areas
and um there's also um a video
online uh which shows
how he distorted the evidence about the
dog experiment there's clips from tv
shows where he's
he claims the dog just goes to the door
over and over again
it's showing the same footage twice in
one case to create the illusion
this has all been exposed over and over
again
but you won't get to realize the
exposure and
if you look at things like wikipedia
which as i say
being captured by groups of skeptical
activists called
guerrilla skeptics on wikipedia and
other um
activist groups i mean i'm not making
this up they have a website
uh guerrilla skeptics on wikipedia i'm
not paranoid
um but when i exposed the guerrilla
skeptics on wikipedia in the blog
three days later they just took down my
own biography page and they've
controlled it ever since they stripped
me of a phd
they said i was a pseudoscientist they
removed all my academic qualifications
they stated i had no papers in
peer-reviewed journals
a few people fought back and managed to
get
at some of the most gross just
distortions corrected
but um they're still in control of this
biography page and so when people
students and others who are trying to
get a sense of what's going on the kind
of area you two are exploring
world views paradigms the view you get
through the regular
orthodox scientific educational system
and through media like wikipedia is
subject to systematic distortion
and i mean that's just what happens when
you have a paradigm a paradigm is a
worldview
people who believe in it think it's true
anything doesn't fit in
with it is marginalized treated as
heresy
um excluded um and that's what's
happening and that's just the way things
are
it's what happened to the theory of
continental drift it's what happens to
all sorts of theories in science
some of them are false but um the
the this kind of um doctrinaire
uh dogmatism is is something
in my view holds back true scientific
inquiry
there is a sense after talking about all
this uh
dogs waiting for their owners to come
home
i'm reminded of argos the odysseus's dog
who waited for him after 20 years or so
the myth goes
and then finally passed after seeing his
master
do you believe and just because we do
have to wrap up uh
so very briefly what do you believe is
the role of myth
in exposing these uh truths
for highlighting these truths is there
any validity to men
well myths are stories that make sense
of the world for us
and um they try and explain the way
things are
in terms of stories about what happened
in the past
and i think they're absolutely essential
for uh
we have to we make sense of the world
through stories
and you know there will be people who'll
tell you world science is different
science is the truth
but actually the big bang theory is our
modern creation myth
um you know there's lots of archaic
creation myths that say the world grew
from the hatching of a cosmic egg
and the cosmic egg gave rise to the
organism of the cosmos that grew
uh from this hatchet hatching of the
cosmic egg
iranian is the hindu myth of the
hatching of the cosmic egg
the golden egg from which the cosmos
comes well the big bang theory is
a modern scientific version of that
cosmogonic myth
and nobody was around at the time of the
big bang to see it
it's not as if it was carefully observed
and written up in full colour photos to
scientific american
by on the spot observers the whole thing
is
a theoretical projection of the way we
see the world now
basically the universe is expanding so
if you scroll it back you get to a point
ultimately where it all collapses in
to the big bang the original point that
that world view assumes that the laws of
nature have always been exactly the same
i don't think they are but anyway i'm
perfectly happy to go along with the big
bang
as a creation myth but i don't think
it's just literal truth
um i think it's the best story we've got
at the moment
and um you know there's a lot in science
which
has this storytelling aspect i mean the
selfish gene
story tells us that dna controls life
and
and everything depends on this selfish
gene which is ruthless and competitive
and when you read richard dawkins on the
subject he's making up myths about dna
it's not scientific language to say dna
is selfish and ruthless and competitive
and we have survival machines that jeans
have built to live in and stuff
um this is all storytelling um
it happens in that case it's very bad
storytelling because
genes have been graciously overrated and
we now know through
the study of epigenetic inheritance that
a lot of inheritance is not based simply
on genes
there are other factors involved so i
would say
we have to have stories and some stories
are better than others
and but it's not as if on one hand
you've got
ancient myths which are sort of
superstitions and on the other hand
you've got science which is true that's
an incredibly naive view
and most scientists who believe science
is true
are incredibly naive um you know they
think they have a superior belief system
to everybody else in fact
they don't even recognize they have a
belief system they think they know the
truth everyone else has beliefs
right there's something called lobs
theorem which says that if you believe
in your own consistency you
automatically become inconsistent which
is related to girdles and completeness
theorem
so also what i was saying earlier about
the belief system of materialists
because their in-belief system actually
makes their own belief in materialism
highly problematic
there is something to be said about
scientists having their own
a sense dogmatism against religion and
what they consider to be supernatural so
if you say is there a creator
no no is there someone pretty much
watching us no are we in the mind of god
no
is there is it possible we're in a
simulation yes
well we're created by that simulation
and in a sense that simulation is
watching
well what's the difference between
they're willing to believe one because
it's more palatable to the scientists
and furthermore how do you decipher
between evidence that is credible and
evidence that is not
credible what is your epistemology in
all of this
okay well first the the the um the
worldview thing you see
i mean i personally find the simulation
theory pretty implausible because it
implies the universe is a gigantic
computer with some kind of programmers
simulating things
i think that's such an anthropocentric
metaphor um
i you know the whole mechanistic theory
is anthropocentric only humans make
machines
and only modern industrial civilizations
are so obsessed with machinery
that they can assume that the whole of
the universe is nothing but machinery
it's unbelievably
provincial even though they supremely
objective
and so the um this world view of the
simulation
uh they it's plausible because to people
who believe in the mechanistic theory
because it sounds technological and
computer-based and they're in
favor of that but basically it's saying
the same thing as one of the ancient
hindu myths
the idea that vishnu lies down the god
vishnu lies down to sleep
and he has a dream and that dream is
this universe and we're within vishnu's
dream
and then eventually traditionally wakes
up this universe disappears and he lies
down
and dreams another universe i mean i
much prefer that myth
to the simulation myth and the vedas
start to interrupt but in the vedas it
is written
that that thing breathless breathed by
its own nature
right and that the idea that the gods
came after
this world's creation that they they
themselves not even know
this world's creation would you say that
this ties
well what i'd say is that the the
deepest views in
hindu and christian and islamic and
other traditions and jewish traditions
in buddhist traditions are that there's
a
a kind of consciousness underlying all
things from which things
come and uh we connect with that through
meditation through
material altered states of consciousness
through
mystical experiences we can have a
direct connection
with that realm um
and that our models of reality if you
then say well
the sun is a god or the moon's goddess
or something like that
these are human ways of modeling this
reality explaining
in terms of stories and myths and in
that sense the gods
in in a polytheistic system where you
have gods of weather and gods of wind
and gods of sea and gods of sky and gods
or goddesses of earth and so on
um these are all sort of projections
and and creations in our own mind but in
all these systems
the idea is that underlying all these is
a realm of consciousness
which you can call it god if you like or
you can call it
ultimate emptiness or nirvana or
whatever or bliss or joy
or i think the best way of thinking of
it in the hindu tradition is through
this threefold uh division ananda
being consciousness bliss um
and joseph campbell speaks about this
yes
well campbell speaks about a whole range
of different myths
and but sanchettananda is um
um a way of having a model of this
ultimate consciousness
without saying god's a creator or sort
of man with a white beard who makes
machinery that's obviously a naive
conception of god and most atheists
assume that
people who believe in god have
incredibly naive views
most of them don't have such naive views
and to add on to your point
uh in orthodox iconography uh
normally the father i.e goddess is
represented by a blue light
right there's this understanding that
you would never depict
a god as a man with a white beard that
this comes much
later in the western tradition around
the time of the renaissance this
anthropomorphization of god
yeah so i i couldn't agree more but
please continue and of course in judaism
there's a prohibition on making any
images of god or the divine because
god's beyond all images and
and in islam as well and so i think that
the
um if we actually take seriously what
serious
theologians and mystics within the
world's religious traditions think about
god
then it's nothing like what atheists
portray them as thinking about god
um you know the god atheist i'm a
christian i'm you know
i'm fine rooted in the mystical
traditions of christianity in my own
thinking and world view um
but when i meet atheists and they tell
me what they think i think
if there's no relation at all they've
got some kind of
something they heard at sunday school
when they were 10 and they think that's
what
serious people think about god um it's
like
sort of dismissing science on the basis
of a misunderstanding of something you
heard in primary school
it's just it is not even
so it doesn't even start as a serious
discussion
um so look oh sorry very quickly when
you look at
these the new atheist movement and their
critiques of the divine
their critiques of god would you say
that the misle
the misleading or the misunderstanding
is based on this natural there's a
supernatural divide
i.e we're in the material world where
there's
toast and mycorrhizal fungi and people
and then there's this supernatural place
with god and demons and angels and
werewolves and vampires and all the
ludicrous nonsense
that we can just sort of shove away and
that there is a fundamentally true
reality
yeah i think it's for it's partly based
on that disastrous division of the
natural and supernatural
it's partly based on that it's partly
based on
historical arguments you know religions
have caused war and conflict
like the inquisition and that sort of
thing um but they conveniently ignore
the fact that in the 20th century
states that had atheist governments as
their official policy and believed in
science and reasons soviet russia
maoris china pol pots cambodia were
responsible for a sort of death on an
industrial scale
unimaginable to the inquisition and the
first bit
aspect of the historical argument it's a
polemical
one-sided rather shallow polemical
arguments which are easy to refute
um and uh which are spoken with the
further of kind of
evangelical creatures um
i just can't take that kind of atheism
seriously there is a kind that i can
take seriously there are some atheists
who say that
god is beyond the ultimate reality is
beyond all human conception
because we have limited minds live on a
small planet in
one galaxy etc therefore ultimate
reality has to be beyond our conceptions
therefore any of our
ideas we may form of god or ultimate
reality
uh ultimately misleading and the truth
goes far beyond them
that's a kind of mystical atheism which
actually is very similar
to mystical theology and in the orthodox
tradition
they the the mainstream theology there
is you probably know is called apophatic
theology
and it's about not saying what god is it
says we can't say what god is we can
only say what god is not
because god's so far beyond our
conception that
uh we can't form a clear image
and so they say there's a certain kind
of atheist which is very close to
apathetic theology and it would
john gray the english atheist writer i
would say was in that category he wrote
an excellent book called seven types of
atheism
which makes it much easier to understand
where the different kinds of atheists
are coming from
and the most superficial and and
and and trivial kind is the kind of
richard dawkins new atheist type
but there are more serious atheist
arguments and um
his book is wonderful introduction to
them
before i pass to uh kirk i just have
one quick thing to say this type of
atheism does have ancient roots right
like protagoras said
as for the gods i cannot say either that
they are or that they are not
or how they are constituted in shape
there's so much that prevents knowledge
of this kind
and clarity of the subject and the
shortness of human life
so before the kind of mystical type of
atheist that there's
our limits of our own minds i mean that
we can't form an adequate conception of
the ultimate
yes yes that has ancient roots and as i
say
in buddhism um the buddha makes the
buddhists
refuse to talk about cosmology and stuff
the idea is the ultimate reality is
beyond all our conceptions
and therefore the only thing to do is to
meditate and experience it directly
rather than just talk about it that
won't get you anywhere so
some people call buddhism atheistic um
and but it's not atheistic in the new
atheist sense it's atheistic in a sense
that goes beyond
the limitations of human thought one of
the most interesting aspects that i find
about
jordan peterson is that he's made
religion sapid
and and intelligible and to the to
people who are formerly or
even current atheists what do you see as
how do you view that and what do you
like about the petersonian approach and
what do you not like
i'm curious to know your thoughts i
think peterson's done a great job
in in bringing up questions serious
important questions and making them
things that a lot of people
see his questions and want to talk about
and discuss
and he's also done a great job in
reaching out to people who
identify as atheists and even
materialists
um i think
so i think that's a tremendous triumph
making intellectual arguments
intellectual discussions
part of popular culture um rather than
just being confined to university
seminar rooms because
he makes the questions real and relevant
i think when it comes to his views on
god
and it's i find it rather hard to know
what he's actually saying i mean he's
talking about young and about archetypes
all very clever
um but you know i'd like to know whether
he goes to church whether he prays and
that sort of thing
i mean i go to church i pray i'm i'm a
practicing anglican
i so you know i don't try to pretend i'm
not
and by just and he may want to
not to say that maybe he doesn't go to
church doesn't pray
maybe he doesn't have any personal
religious faith or practice
maybe he just thinks religion is a good
thing in the abstract or in or
good for people's psyche or fits with
the right archetypes
it's awfully hard i mean i know there
are people who've watched hundreds of
hours of jordan peterson
i'm i've only watched it much less than
that so
it may be he clarifies this somewhere
but the ones i've seen i found a bit
frustrating
well what's next for you and where can
our audience find out more about you
well they can find anyone can find out
more about me on my website
sheldrake.org
which links to my youtube channel where
there are many videos and dialogues and
discussions and
so there's plenty of information there
my book sounds set free it summarizes my
views about
the need to go beyond materialistic uh
science into a wider more inclusive and
holistic paradigm
my two most recent books um where
i try to bring together my scientific
understanding of the world with
spiritual practices
but one is called science and spiritual
practices deals with seven different
spiritual practices including meditation
gratitude connecting with nature and
pilgrimage
and as the most recent book ways to go
beyond and why they work
is about seven more spiritual practices
including sports
learning from animals fasting
and spiritual openings through
psychedelics
and the celebration of holy days and
festivals all of these are practices
which can be done within or outside the
framework of any particular religion
and now all of them are being studied
scientifically
in a way that um brings science and
spirituality into a complementary and
mutually helpful relationship
rather than some kind of antagonistic
slanging match
um and that's much more constructive and
helpful anyway that's
that's the theme of my most recent books
and as for what comes next i'm using
this period of enforced
grounding in in my home in in in london
um as
actually i see it as a wonderful
blessing because
i'm writing scientific papers now i've
got about seven or eight papers
based on data from my experiments um and
uh other ideas which i've wanted to
write out for years and have never had
the time and now i have so
um talking of peer-reviewed journals i'm
now in full peer-reviewed journal
mode um i'm writing finished one last
week i'm writing another right now
um so um that that's what i'm up to at
the moment
rupert your pleasure to talk to a
pleasure to listen to thank you so much
right well good luck good luck to both
of you with your project
and your inquiry is really important